[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro des matins du
sénat arnaud montebourg fait son retour
au sénat l'ancien ministre de l'économie
et du redressement productif de françois
hollande est auditionné ce matin par les
sénateurs sur la suppression de 1000
emplois dans les usines du groupe
general electric
il y a quatre ans arnaud montebourg
avait qualifié d' erreur majeure la
vente de la branche énergie d'alstom à
l'américain general electric ce groupe
s'était alors engagé à créer 1000
emplois engagement qu'il n'a pas
respectée désormais arnaud montebourg
demande à l'état d'annuler cette vente
de 2014
je vous laisse écouter son audition nous
avons le plaisir de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui monsieur montebourg aussi un
ministre évidemment de l'économie du
redressement productif comme l'on disait
à ce moment-là et du numérique
aujourd'hui entrepreneur monsieur le
ministre le 24 mars 2014 était
promulguée la loi visant à reconquérir
l'économie réelle dite loi florange
celle-ci issue d'initiative
parlementaire élaboré dans un contexte
difficile d'arrêt des hauts fourneaux de
moselle avait pour objectif de protéger
l'emploi industriel est l'appareil
productif français le prévoyait
notamment une obligation de recherche de
repreneurs lors de toute fermeture de
sites cinq ans plus tard force est de
constater que la dynamique de
désindustrialisation malheureusement se
poursuit chaque année près de 50000
emplois industriels sont détruits depuis
1989 c'est presque un million et demi
d'emplois industriels qui ont disparu
c'est 30% de moins cette tendance n'est
pas une spécificité française nous
devons bien le dire mais est le plus
aigu dans notre pays que chez nos
voisins la part de l'industrie
manufacturière dans notre pib est
aujourd'hui environ de 10% contre très
pratiquement 13 en espagne pratiquement
15 en italie et surtout pratiquement 21
en allemagne il est vrai que notre
économie a bénéficié d'un répit ces deux
dernières années certains indicateurs
sortant du rouge mais la dynamique de
fond n'est pas encore enrayée d'ailleurs
alors que le gouvernement actuel se
félicite de la croissance des
investissements étrangers en france
nous voyons de près dans les territoires
les conséquences des plans sociaux mise
en oeuvre par des groupes étrangers dans
des usines françaises récemment acheté
en mai dernier général
electric annonçait la suppression de
plus de 1000 emplois dans ses activités
françaises de la branche gaz cela
intervient moins de cinq ans après le
rachat de la branche énergie d'alstom
par le groupe américain au cours duquel
celui-ci avait pris des engagements
devant l'état en matière de création
d'emplois monsieur le ministre vous
étiez alors au gouvernement
après avoir évoqué la nationalisation
partielle d'alstom vous avez finalement
avalisé la cession en contrepartie de
promesses general electric peu après
vous quittiez le gouvernement et vous
avez récemment déclaré cette histoire
est une humiliation nationale
la france a été vendu et abandonné
dénonçant une erreur majeure dans leur
rapport d'information qui est paru en
avril 2018 nos collègues alain chatillon
et martial bourquin qui est ici relevait
que les discussions portant sur la
cession de cet actif stratégique
d'alstom s'était déroulée sans
information préalable de l'état
de surcroît cet actif ne tombait pas
sous coup la procédure d'autorisation
préalable des investissements étrangers
en réaction aux mai 2014 au gouvernement
prenait le décret auquel vous avez
laissé votre nom incluant l'énergie les
transports parmi les secteurs d'activité
sensibles au delà de ces derniers
développements le cas d'alstom et
general electric pose la question des
outils à la disposition de l'état pour
anticiper les cessions d'actifs
stratégiques en particulier des groupes
étrangers et leurs conséquences sur
l'emploi industriel dans les territoires
ne nous trompons pas cet enjeu touche
tous les secteurs de notre industrie je
suis sam ans récemment rendu avec les
sénateurs et d'ailleurs les députés
également du calvados haqqani une
sucrerie de saint louis sucre racheté
dans les années 2000 par le groupe
allemand tout son coeur va arrêter toute
production et si l'on en croit
l'industriel allemand l'arrêt de la
production est motivée par la volonté de
redresser les cours mondiaux du sucre
axa permettez moi de rappeler sens
ironique les deux usines françaises
concernées par ce plan ne représente que
0,4 pour cent de la production mondiale
cette décision pénalise avec certitude
deux bassins de production en france
sans qu'il y ait quelconque assurance
que cette production sera réduite
ailleurs en europe j'ajoute que le
simple fait de maintenir une activité de
stockage dans l' usine exemple
industriellement de ses obligations à la
fois de dépollution des sols et de
l'appliquer
sur la loi florange cela tu réduis
largement la probabilité de faire
prospérer
l'offre des acteurs locaux planteurs
betteraviers de reprendre l'usiné pour
sauver la production les mêmes problèmes
se posent donc dans toutes nos filière
productique monsieur le ministre avant
de vous laisser la parole
voici les questions que je souhaite vous
adresser au niveau de l'anticipation des
rachats d'entreprises et des décisions
affectant l'emploi industriel français
l'état dispose-t-il selon vous des
outils adaptés de surveillance d' alerte
et de réflexion stratégique
un décret de mars 2019 a récemment
rénové la gouvernance de la politique de
sécurité économique qui inclut un
commissaire à l'information stratégique
et à la sécurité économique et un
service de l'information stratégique
quelle appréciation en faites-vous la
loi florange suffit-elle encore
aujourd'hui à protéger les emplois
industriels des territoires français
nous avons vu qu'elle peut être
contournée qu'elle l'est d'ailleurs
assez facilement via le maintien de
quelques salariés sur un site alors que
l'on supprime qu'on le modifie la
majeure partie de l'activité
comment combattre ces pratiques qui vont
à l'encontre de l'esprit même de la loi
comment distinguer les véritables
investissements étrangers productifs qui
ce qui apporte du capital annoncent à
notre en distribuer des emplois et ceux
qui sont prédateurs et qui sont
préalables à la délocalisation
quelquefois au ce qu'on pourrait appeler
le vol de technologies
le décret le fameux décret mon lourd et
ses élargissements successifs
couvre-t-il tout le champ des actifs
stratégiques
dans le cas des engagements de general
electric où vous avez pris une part très
importante vis-à-vis du gouvernement
pourquoi l'état français est il était
impuissant à les faire à faire respecter
les engagements de general electric et
vous comprendrez bien qu'il en va de la
crédibilité de nos politiques publiques
et puis dernière chose la loi pacte à
renforcer le contrôle du parlement sur
l'activité du gouvernement en matière de
protection des intérêts économiques
quelle est votre vision sur cette
arrivée
j'allais dire du parlement dans les
affaires d'intelligence économique voilà
j'ai posé beaucoup de questions qu'il ya
un peu longue mais ce ministre vous êtes
naturellement la parole et puis je pense
que mes collègues vous poseront
directement leurs questions
ce ministre
tel un petit bouton celui-là merci merci
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
merci de cette présentation finalement
assez crue et cruelle de la situation
dans laquelle notre pays se trouve je
j'essaierai de répondre si j'oublie un
des points sur lesquels vous voulez
insisté vous me rappellerai jeu j'y
reviendrai si j'ai pas eu le temps de
tout noté nous nous posons la question
de savoir
je crois que c'est une vision assez je
vais dire lucide de la situation
économique
si un pays comme la france qui est un
grand pays économique très créatif sur
le plan scientifique technologique
industriel est menacé par finalement des
prises de contrôle qui font migrer les
centres de décision de l'avenir de ses
unités de production sur le territoire
national hors de france bon c'est une
vision il y a dix ans qui aurait été
condamné de toutes parts chacun aurait
dit mais c'est de la xénophobie
économique est aujourd'hui chacun
commence à prendre conscience que nous
sommes dans une guerre économique où les
états à dos des entreprises
transnationales pour prendre des parts
de marché attaquer les d'autres nations
dans leurs ressources économiques
technologiques et donc la naïveté n'est
donc plus de mise
donc je crois que vous posez vous
permettrai de le dire assez librement la
question mais fait d'eux des risques de
dévitalisation de notre économie en
rapport avec la liberté qu'on a laissé
qu'on a offertes à des investisseurs
étrangers de faire leur shopping dans
l'économie et l'industrie française
j'ai envie de dire et l'agriculture
parce qu'il n'ya pas que l'industrie il
est aussi l'agriculture une vision assez
mais ligne n 2
la république les deux mamelles de la
france et les cultures industrielles
sont bien entamés bien abîmée alors si
je peux livrer une expérience courte un
temps certes mais courte de ces deux ans
et demi passés à bercy avec mandat de me
battre pour sauver le plus possible donc
vision défensive préserver le plus
possible c'est à dire ne pas accepter
les défaisant ce les faillites les
délocalisations tout ce que finalement
la mondialisation présenté comme
heureuse a rendu parfaitement normal est
possible et donc presque finalement
organisant l'impuissance de la puissance
publique la puissance publique devant la
puissance d'un employé ce mot et je
crois qu'il est juste qu est-ce qu on
peut en retirer à chaque fois qu'une de
nos grandes entreprises transnationales
a fait l'objet de mesures de
consolidation dans un cadre où ce
n'était pas la france qui rachetaient
mais c'étaient d'autres qui rachetaient
des entreprises françaises à capitaux
localiser français historiquement
français je veux parler des grandes
entreprises du cac 40 premières
cotations du sur le sur la bourse
euronext cac 40 et bien à chaque fois
qu'on a accepté ça le même scénario
s'est toujours réaliser toujours depuis
20 ans ça a commencé avec pechiney qui
est la première finalement prise de
contrôle agressive non non acceptées par
le gouvernement de l'époque et j'ai
rencontré à l'occasion des difficultés
que nous avons eu à connaître tous mes
anciens collègues ministres économie
nous formons une sorte de j'allais dire
de comment dire de deux confréries les
déçus un monsieur thierry breton à
passant par monsieur strauss kahn tous
ceux qui ont eu en charge l'économie de
ce pays à chaque fois ont vu la même
histoire donc ça a été pechiney pris par
alcan vendus par à rio tinto démentez
par alcan et rio tinto
alors il reste des tas d usine
tous les sens partout mais c'était une
magnifique entreprise à l'époque le
gouvernement du président chirac n'a pas
cru utile s'y opposer monsieur breton en
charge s'est battu comme il l'a pu avec
les moyens qu'on lui a laissé parce
qu'il paraissait incongrue de se
défendre après il ya eu la sphère mittal
notre acier arcelor nous avons connu
sous tous les cas kenna chirac sarkozy
hollande et bientôt macron les mêmes
prises de décision
à partir du moment où vous laisser la
prise de décisions sortir du territoire
national eh bien vous avez des intérêts
qui ne sont plus ceux de la france vous
avez des intérêts qui sont ailleurs
alors je ne juge pas ce sont des
intérêts divergents et différents mais
vous comprenez déjà dans une grande
entreprise
les intérêts sont déjà française avec un
siège social en france
un board français un capital
majoritairement actionnariat de
référence au delà 15 20 % le reste la
bourse étant flottante à peu près avec
une sensibilité
j'allais dire enraciné on va dire avec
une histoire une géographie française
déjà là vous avez des conflits parce que
quand vous êtes une grande entreprise
française
vous avez besoin d'aller conquérir des
marchés dont vous avez besoin
d'installer des établissements et des
filiales dans les pays pour produire sur
place parce que les gouvernements vous
le demande quand vous voulez prendre des
parts de marché mais alors quand vous
perdez le centre de décision vous perdez
tout donc on a tout perdu dans tous ces
secteurs
c'est à dire perdre et bien sûr le
contrôle mais surtout les laboratoires
de r d vous avez ensuite les usines de
fabrication et à chaque fois c'est le
même scénario
et je vais vous dire notre naïveté c'est
de ne pas avoir réagi beaucoup plus tôt
après je peux continuer la litanie si
vous voulez après en ce qui nous
concerne ce fut alstom qui a fait
l'objet
d'une prise de contrôle agressive
inamicale avec trahison des dirigeants
d'alstom parce que c'est toujours comme
ça vous avez toujours des français qui
aide la puissance adverse à s'emparer
d'eux c'est toujours comme ça donc on
peut considérer que c'est ce qui s'est
passé sur alstom
il a fallu inventer des stratagèmes ce
décret dont vous avez mentionné
l'existence qui nous a permis
d'améliorer les conditions de la
négociation mais là c'est une question à
laquelle je réponds de votre part madame
la prison le 10 mai ce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose réponse on peut bloquer
les ventes on pouvait bloquer la vente
d'alstom puisque j'avais fait arracher
ce décret au premier ministre de
l'époque monsieur valls est que le
décret permettait ce signature du
ministre d'économie de dire c'est un
actif stratégique il est hors de
question de le céder c'était une
décision d'ailleurs j'ai défendu dans
l'arbitrage collégial dans le salon vert
de l'elysée en présence du président de
la république de son conte secrétaire
général monsieur juillet son secrétaire
général adjoint monsieur macron le
premier ministre je crois qu'il y avait
encore le ministre des finances monsieur
sapin nous étions cinq autour de la
table j'ai défendu le blocage de la
vente
l'addition était prise par le président
de la république de l'époque monsieur
hollande ne pas ne ne pas bloquer donc
nous avons moins de le faire il faut
juste prendre son courage à deux mains
et défendre la france est-ce que nous
avons les dirigeants pour le faire la
preuve à chaque fois maintenant nous
avons des outils et on m'avait prédit
sous le sou des questions très
agressives de l'assemblée nationale que
la commission européenne s'opposerait à
ce décret je me souviens encore avoir
défendu j'ai dit mais là que la
commission européenne n'a rien à voir là
dedans elle n'a pas à s'opposer à ce que
la france a comme conception de la
mondialisation ne s'agit pas d'un
problème entre l'allemagne la france
marché intérieur d'ailleurs si moi
j'avais eu des propositions et contre
propositions à faire peut-être qu'elle
aurait été beaucoup plus européenne que
la solution general electric qui a été
choisie qui nous conduit à subir des
décisions plutôt que les maîtriser à
subir les décisions d'un d'une
multinationale qui a des problèmes
économiques à gérer et qui le fait
évident
quant au profit de ses propres intérêts
américains et au détriment des intérêts
périphériques belfort belfort passera
bien après on l'a eu dans ses trois
grands sujets et ça a continué avec
technip
alors ça c'est monsieur macron technip
des techniques c'est et lafarge holcim
voilà vous en avez trois en cinq ans
technip
c'est la même histoire sauf que vous
avez là aussi un dirigeant de pimco qui
n'a aucune espèce de reconnaissance pour
son pays
vous avez dans l'actionnariat la bpi
quand même l'institut français du
pétrole je rappelle que technip aînés
les brevets de l'institut français du
pétrole qui a été créé par le général de
gaulle pour permettre à la france dans
le secteur de hull en gaz comme on dit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire les huiles
d'extraction et le pétrole extrait
d'être un acteur majeur ce que nous
sommes encore grâce à total c'était
l'époque elf essence lubrifiants de
france donc les fp et l outil de
recherche publique au service de cette
économie là dont nous nous en nous nous
avons vion besoin pour des raisons
stratégiques et nous sommes nous sommes
retrouvés avec une direction de technip
monsieur pilenko qui qui est le
président de cette entreprise
actionnariat quand même public pas
majoritaires mais quand même public sont
allés faire une fausse fusion entre
égaux avec une boîte en faillite dont la
valorisation est le contenu de la gelée
dire la solidité des actifs a été
surévaluée sur mandat d'une banque
d'affaires américaine qui a menti sur le
contenu de ce qu'on achetait et qu'on
achetait pas en vérité puisque cfmc qui
rachetaient technique c'était n'était
pas une fusion entre égaux
c'est quand même 70 mille salariés dans
le monde technip c'est une cotation cac
ce n'est pas connue des français parce
que c'est us et une cdu be to be s'est
pas de durite elles connues des
consommateurs
enfin c'est fondamental pour notre
présence sur la question énergétique
actuelle et à venir et donc nous sommes
retrouvés avec déménagement du siège
social 700 emplois au siège qui ont été
supprimés à paris
et des gens qui ont reçu des chèques
puisque la totalité du conseil
d'administration a été remerciée vu ses
émolument x x j'ai perdu le shift
tellement ma mémoire est incapable de
j'allais dire conserver le montant de la
trahison
mais pour moi pour moi ce sont des
abandons et qui ont été décidés il était
parfaitement possible ministre
d'économie sur la base de mon décret de
dire eh bien cette vente n'aura pas lieu
alors après qu'est ce que nous avons vu
nous avons des syndicats qui débarque et
le parlement qui arrive c'est normal et
on découvre l'ampleur des dégâts le
gouvernement fait ça dans son coin
il n'y a aucune transparence sur ces
sujets je dois dire que le décret du 14
mai 2014 dont vous allez appeler
l'existence n'a pas été utilisé pour
quelle raison il aurait pu l'être
parfaitement je pense qu'il n'aurait pas
pu l'être dans la sphère lafarge holcim
mais il aurait pu l'être dans technip
aurait pu l'être dans alstom je les dis
et combien d'autres encore donc nous
avons les moyens
premièrement de bloquer ses pertes de
contrôle deuxièmement vous posez la
question des engagements de l'état
j'avais dans la négociation un peu le
dos au mur dans la mesure où le
président de la république me dit on va
vendre à general electric
donc trouve le moyen pour que ce soit le
mieux possible bon j d'abord la première
chose c'est on nationalise alstom
d'abord parce qu alstom c'est un bien
plus commun je rappelle président
sarkozy a nationalisé alston s'il est
utile de le rappeler je les rappelait
d'ailleurs au président olemps lui dis
ce que finalement le président hollande
peut faire moins que le président
sarkozy jeu c'est comme ça que j'ai
arraché l'arbitrage face à aux
conseillers au pluriel de l'époque de du
président aux lentilles disait on n'est
quand même pas au venezuela que je sache
la présidence sarkozy ne ressemblaient
pas à celles du venezuela
voilà l'état d'esprit auquel nous avons
à faire face
s'agissant des grands dirigeants de ce
pays quand même hein donc moi je ne
je n'ai pas approuvé cette période
c'était de combats intenses et internes
j'ai perdu mais j'ai au moins arracher
la possibilité de faire trois
coentreprises
pourquoi on avait fait des trois contre
je vais vous le dire parce que ça a des
conséquences aujourd'hui
j'avais dit bon ils veulent vendre à
géra électrique très bien ils trouvent
ça a certainement plus sexy qu'un accord
avec siemens on aurait eu plus de mal à
trouver un accord avec siemens que les
allemands sont en position de force au
sein de l'union européenne mais au moins
on aurait eu les moyens de contrôler la
sphère belfort l'allemagne ça c'est et
les allemands ne sont pas des gens qui
qui sont insensibles à la question
industrielle des emplois les américains
se débarrasse en dix minutes de dix
mille personnes
les allemands y négocier ils ont des
syndicats ils comprennent ce que c'est
qu'un territoire
bref non la même culture du capitalisme
rhénan de part et d'autre du rhin donc
on pouvait au moins s'entendre sur les
façons dont on pouvait adapter la
l'outil industriel
en tout cas cette décision n'a pas été
prise donc sommes retrouvés avec les
américains qui eux mêmes sont ans sont
en situation de force
d'abord parce que ce sont des
investisseurs importants sur le
territoire national et nous avions un
précédent qui était constructif et
positif dans l'alliance que l'ancien
snecma avait eu avec general electric
sur les moteurs d'avion qui sait ce
qu'on appelle c'est le cfm56 et avait ce
moteur d'avion a été conçu construit par
general electric et safran à 50/50
depuis 45 ans d'ailleurs nous sommes
allés à washington je crois en 2014 pour
célébrer cet anniversaire
c'est l'exemple d'une coentreprise à 50
50 avec après guerre deux industriels un
français très bon d'aéronautique et
américains très bon aéronautique fait
c'étaient les sous traitants de boeing
et du futur airbus qui se mettent
d'accord pour faire le moteur qui va
prendre la principale part de marché
dans le monde
il ya aujourd'hui dans le monde
1 cf n 56 qui atterrit où se posent
toutes les deux secondes
c'est vous dire la puissance que 7 à
coentreprise avait réussi à créer donc
moi j'ai dit aux américains les j'ai
obtenu l'autorisation du président de
négocier trois coentreprises sur ce
modèle-là disant on va se mettre
d'accord sur trois sujets qui concernent
l'avenir alors la dignité quoi c'était
le nucléaire nucléaire pas l'abandonner
comme ça donc on l'isolent et on met
dans une coentreprise avec une golden
share de la france détient un droit de
veto du gouvernement français sur tout
ce que vous allez faire et on contrôlera
tout ce que vous faites parce que ses
notes nucléaire c'est nos bâtiments
militaires
donc c'était un moindre mal 2 les
énergies renouvelables ou alstom avait
investi et qui intéressait à l'époque
j'ai réécrit je rappelle que à l'époque
l'hydraulique
c'est à dire les turbines pour les
barrages nous étions nous avions 25 % de
parts de marché dans le monde
donc c'était très intéressant on a quand
même équipe et les grands barrages
chinois parlent usine de grenoble qui
anciennement neyrpic avaient été achetés
alstom c'est une entreprise très
brillante que jamal triki est en train
de démanteler à grenoble ben je le
rappelle est vendre aux chinois
si vous voulez et là aussi il y aura des
choses à faire à dire c'est pour ça que
c'est très bien que vous je réponds à
votre dernière question par la même
occasion c'est très bien vous en occuper
il faut quelqu'un quelque part que
l'opinion publique
les français et leurs représentants
légitimes que vous êtes est désigné
s'occupe de ses problèmes ne les laisse
pas à quelques experts plus ou moins
dans la main de puissance privée faire
leur fortune comme disait ruy blas faire
leur fortune privée dans un coin de la
fortune publique
voilà j'aime beaucoup cette phrase de
victor hugo elle est venue toute seule
ma la présence excusez moi alors c'est
sûr que ça marche bien
un grand sénateur grand-père de france
alors c'est évident que ces
coentreprises
alors il y avait les énergies
renouvelables pardonnez moi j'ai fait
une digression
et puis il y avait les réseaux réseaux
c'est évidemment le point de
développement futur pour l'énergie donc
énergies renouvelables nucléaire réseau
la vapeur c'est à dire le charbon on
peut considérer que c'est en descente et
le gars c'était la technologie jeraill
trick puisque ashton avait racheté une
technologie qui n'était pas tout à fait
au point
et donc c'était déjà eu la meilleure
technologie était déjà chez general
electric donc ces trois points là nous
permettait d'avoir finalement quelques
milliards entreposés dans ses valeurs et
de technologie et de souveraineté
préserver dans ses trois coentreprises
qui nous permettait de voir venir
nous avions la possibilité d'en racheter
une sur les 3 mais nous pouvions bloquer
le rachat par ge et électriques des deux
autres donc on pouvait maintenir une
position
il y avait un mélange de gouvernance
alors d'ailleurs il devait y avoir un
centre le centre de direction d'une des
coentreprises devait rester à belfort
négociation cash et un salon de chaud et
puis jeudi face à ces coentreprises il
faut quand même que il ya de la
puissance en face parce que si c'est la
direction de ferroviaire restantes
d'alstom puisqu'en fait il restait plus
que le ferroviaire et la mobilité et
signale il y avait plus personne de
l'énergie tout le monde était parti
générique donc fallu mettre quelqu'un en
face capable de s'opposer à gérer les
tricks 250 milliards d'un côté ça c'est
le poids de électrique 25 milliards
avant la vente de 12 milliards chez
alstom donc on va mettre l'état
face pour défendre nos intérêts et puis
en attendant que ckoi entreprise
prospère
on verra ce qu'on fera un dernier donc
c'est une position d'attenté et j'avais
dît si vous ne créez pas mille emplois
c'était la première fois que dans un
accord on signait ce type de ce qui
était difficile à l'arraché de façon
nocturne je me souviens avec nos
négociateurs et négociateur que j'avais
mandaté avec les équipes de alstom qui
n'en voulait pas et j'irai à littry qui
ne voulait surtout pas ce qui était des
amendes pour le cas où il ne
respecteraient pas leurs engagements
c'était une amende symbolique parce que
pour eux 50 millions ce n'est rien mais
c'était un début j'ai regretté de ne pas
être beaucoup plus exigeant finalement
parce que j'aurais dû mettre la clause
de retour en l'état antérieur si les
accords n'étaient pas respectées donc
j'ai un regret c'est de ne pas avoir été
plus dur dans la négociation mais je
n'avais pas les coudées franches pour
aller beaucoup beaucoup plus loin mais
le retour en l'état antérieur c'est
aujourd'hui juridiquement si vous me
permettez l'expression
ce qu'il conviendrait d'obtenir car il
n'ya pas respect d'un accord
donc il y a eu des manoeuvres dolosives
nous le savons à cause du témoignage de
monsieur pierre uci a été
instrumentalisé par le department of
justice pour faire pression sur le board
de alstom pour qu'ils vendent dans des
conditions inacceptables à toute vitesse
dans le dos de son gouvernement
la branche énergie d'alstom pour moi
cette vente et dolosive et en droit
français
une vente qui a été réalisé par une
violation du consentement peut être
annulée à la demande d'une des parties
donc aujourd'hui l'état français à la
peau aurait la possibilité du cas je
serai ministre d'économie
je saisirai le tribunal de céans comme
on dit chez les juristes étaient
incompétents
je pense que ce serait plutôt la cour
d'appel de paris pour faire annuler
l'accord et rétablir les choses en
l'état antérieur
ça nous donnerait beaucoup de
négociations de capacité de négociation
dans la
d'actuels donc moi je ne peux que vous
dire madame la présidente mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
le gouvernement a la possibilité de
défendre juridiquement un accord qui a
été négocié tel qu'il l'a été mais dans
la mesure où nous savons aujourd'hui
dans quelles conditions la négociation a
eu lieu eh bien nous sommes en mesure de
faire respecter la france tout cas c'est
mon opinion juridique et je ne suis pas
le seul à le penser parmi les juristes
qui se penche sur cette affaire et il
est évident que les révélations
publiques de l'un des hauts cadres
d'alstom qui est sorti de prison aux
etats-unis qui a expliqué comment il
avait été instrumentalisé faire plaidé
coupable comment d'ailleurs monsieur
kron lui-même a plaidé coupable
1 il est donc donc il reconnu comment
donc
en vérité alstom est une entreprise qui
était fragilisée en raison dé mener de
ses dirigeants et comment donc alstom a
été sous la pression judiciaire du des
logis aussi longtemps que la vente n'a
pas été réalisée nous avons là les
conditions du dol voilà mon point de vue
c'est une réaction et je pense que comme
monsieur treuil n'aime pas les taxes
gaffard et qu'il est en train de prendre
des décisions punitive vis-à-vis de la
france qui serait temps de maintenant de
commencer à se prémunir et à s'armer
contre les excès de puissance de la part
de nos anciens alliés je n'appelle pas
ça une alliance ou une amitié
je considère que maintenant nous avons
face à nous deux empires chinois et
américains qui ont décidé de s'entendre
sur notre dos donc que font les
européens
est-ce que nous allons réarmer la
puissance publique alors nous avons des
armes
il suffirait que nous ayons les
dirigeants capables de les utiliser
voilà ça c'est une autre question
détails dès qu'elle permettrait de ne
pas entrer alors après les outils de
surveillance écoutez moi j'ai une
expérience qui est très négative
finalement dans la sphère alstom on n'a
rien vu ni quand j'ai appelé le
contre-espionnage on m'a dit on espionne
pas nos amis américains alors que eux
avaient quand même réalisé 75 millions
d' écoute sur pendant douze mois c'est
ce qu'a révélé monsieur snowden 75
oui millions de conversations ou de
mails ou de sms qui ont été écoutés et
lorsque monsieur karoutchi est arrivé
devant la justice américaine
la justice extraterritoriale amérique n
ya pas de préjudice sur le territoire
américain
il n'y avait pas de préjudice au
détriment des états unis où d'une
entreprise américaine il n'y avait pas
de plaignant
donc c'était une position
extraterritoriale du department of
justice américain de faire la police du
monde sur la corruption sur tous les
continents tous les sujets qui
l'intéressent et en vérité ils ont sorti
de 1 million de mails à charge contre
alstom qui provenaient des écoutes de la
nsa
pourquoi la la loi des extra
territoriales américaines qui a mis en
en pouvoir le department of justice de
pouvoir poursuivre n'importe quelle
entreprise européenne et d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez qu'ils ne poursuivent que
des entreprises étrangères
jamais ou très rarement des entreprises
américaines et si je regarde la somme
des condamnations qui sont qui ont
abouti contre les entreprises
européennes on est on est pas très loin
de plusieurs dizaines de milliards de da
manque donc ça c'est des substances que
les américains ont décidé nous prendre
c'est la substance économique
y a pas que la bnp ses 9 milliards vous
avez siemens vous en avez un paquet une
entreprise allemande française et qui
ont été condamnés et d'autres sont
encore en cours vous pouvez comprendre
que cette loi qui date de 1978 a pris
une ampleur beaucoup plus efficiente et
efficace dans la stratégie du
gouvernement et de la puissance de
jaillir de l' empire américain
à partir du moment où ils ont utilisé la
msa pour capturer les conversations sans
aucune réaction des puissances écoutez
nous en sommes donc quand vous arrivez
vous êtes cadre alstom n - deux patrons
des chaudières
monde et conduit ben voilà on a un
million de mails et que votre avocat
américain commis d'office vous dit il
faudra trois ans pour que je les examine
et vous est incarcéré et qu'on vous dit
mais qu'une seule chose à faire c'est
plaider coupable si c'est pas une
pression je veux bien être moi même
soumis à la question d'idéologie
voilà ça c'est la réalité de la guerre
économique
c'est ce que la france a subi donc c'est
une humiliation nationale
en effet et elles méritent une
réparation elle mérite en tout cas que
des mesures soient prises pour rétablir
nos intérêts je ne parle pas je ne
devrais pas parler trop affectivement
même si l'émotion parfois traversé mon
coeur mais ça ça n'a pas d'importance
nous ne sommes pas là pour ça en
revanche les intérêts de notre pays doit
être préservé et pour ça là il ya des
mesures à prendre
donc on peut parfaitement demander
l'annulation du de là quand ça plaira ni
à monsieur crown ya monsieur bouygues
mais c'est pas grave
la france passe avant tout le monde
c'est comme ça voilà alors vous m'avez
je crois questionné sur comment
distinguer le prédateur
de l'investisseur écoutez on le connaît
à l usage c'est pourquoi il est utile
d'imaginer que maintenant quand on fera
usage du décret devrait vous faire usage
de décret en posant des conditions comme
le fel si fussent américains savent
qu'en fait ce que nous nous avions
imaginé
c'est la réciprocité vis-à-vis du
comportement du gouvernement américain
qui peut prendre sans voie de recours
sur décision du président des états unis
des mesures et ça a été le cas pour une
entreprise comme thales qui a investi
aux états unis ils ont été interdits
d'avoir essayé aux français ils ont eu
un board qui était majoritairement
composée obligatoirement par des
américains et toute décision
d'investissement devait être approuvé
par le board à majorité américaines donc
en vérité ils ont accepté
l'investissement étranger à condition
qu' ils soient dirigées par des
américains mais je propose qu'on fasse
la même chose et le décret permet de le
faire c'est à dire que vous dites
la plupart des décisions du cif us ne
sont jamais des interdictions ce sont
seulement des autorisation sous
conditions par exemple quand je crois il
ya des investisseurs du golfe qui ont
voulu acheter les ports les ports
américains certains ports américains une
interdiction formelle sécurité nationale
mais la plupart du temps ce sont des
conditions qui sont fixés par le stif us
donc il serait utile que nous fixions
nous mêmes des conditions disant vous
allez prendre tel board
je vais choisir le pdg j'aurai la
majorité du contrôle de ce si vous
n'avez pas le droit de coter en bout et
pas loin de faire si vous n'êtes pas
loin de faire ça si vous le faites c'est
avec mon autorisation pourrait faire le
même on décrète permet et les conditions
et si vous ne respectez pas d'accord on
annuler la vente et on va devant le
tribunal n'a pas besoin de faire des
lois tout ça tout ça nous avons
l'appareil juridique mais nous n'avons
pas l'appareillage politique où le
dispositif humain on pourrait dire ça
comme ça
voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près
répondu à vos questions alors sur le
sucre peut-être un mauvais prix puisque
vous
c'est tout à fait embarrassant parce que
ça c'est un rapport avec la loi florange
peut-être qu'on pourrait dire un mot que
je vais peut-être pas m'éterniser
spécialement beaucoup de questions alors
la sphère agricole c'est la fin des
quotas
les quotas permettait quoi des prix des
quantités garantie parti au moment où
l'union européenne décide de mettre les
paysans européens sur le marché mondial
sans protection donc sans mesure de
protection de leurs prix à partir de ce
moment là vous avez tout le problème de
la conjugaison des questions climatiques
qui sont la nature est capricieuse
qu'ils produisent pas donc une
irrégularité de la production donc quand
vous êtes en haut de cycle les prix ça
fais quand vous êtes en bas de cycle les
prix montent donc si vous pensez que en
réduisant des capacités de façon
définitive pour intervenir sur un prix
alors qu'en fait la bonne méthode
c'était celle des vieilles d'office du
vin et du blé qu'on avait conçu sur le
front populaire et que la politique
agricole commune avait mis en place
c'est le seul moyen de réguler des prix
de protéger des protections de protéger
des productions et de garantir une
souveraineté alimentaire et de
l'autosuffisance
c'est comme ça qu'on l'avait fait mais
les libéraux dire les partisans du
laisser-faire et du marche du tout
marché ont pris le pouvoir dans l'union
européenne ont réussi à mettre des
paysans européens donc français sur le
marché mondial dans le guen protection
donc vous avez des industriels de la
transformation de la betterave du sucre
qui disent moi je peux plus vendre non
sud donc je suis dit je suis donc
puisque le le cours fait le yoyo donc
moi je me mets ainsi que le bas pour
garantir que finalement mes prix vont
remonter puis d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses entre nous y compris ça dans
vos visites haqqani je crois entre nous
on peut même se dire que si jamais la
production doit remonter je la ferai pas
remonter en france voilà parce que donc
ce sont des délocalisation déguisée
voilà alors est ce que la loi florange
étaient pertinentes
elle avait de bonnes intentions mais
elle n'a pas mis en place
l'arsenal de sanctions qui auraient
permis de se faire respecter donc elle
n'est pas respectée
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions si vous
avez un problème avec une entreprise qui
est rentable qui a des donc si elle est
rentable vous avez des candidats à la
reprise
vous n'avez pas d'autres solutions nous
on l'a fait on l'a fait dans un cas de
qui étaient dans leur on voulait sauver
une papeterie d'un groupe en déconfiture
le groupe est en déconfiture mais
l'entreprise elle-même l'unité de
production était parfaitement rentable
très outillé avec des savoir faire
donc en fait on a trouvé une solution je
me souviens j'en avais pas avec le
président du département de l'eure et
nous avons fait une sorte de non pas
nationalisation mais on a fait à
l'allemande qui le font à travers les
lander de départementalisation ils ont
racheté le site est telle qu'elle est
l'employeur
enfin le thaïlandais qui s'est installé
et je crois qu'il a réembauché depuis
c'est reparti à thaïlandais qui
voulaient reprendre la route prix donc
en fait c'est la puissance publique qui
a s'est approprié l'outil de travail et
l'a transmis à un repreneur n'a pas
d'autre choix
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire dans
la sphère dit de florange d'ailleurs
j'avais obtenu à l'époque le soutien de
consensuel de la totalité de la classe
politique
je me souviens que outre le groupe de
l'époque auquel j'appartenais groupe
socialiste l'ensemble du gouvernement
soutenait la position de la
nationalisation temporaire d
des hauts fourneaux de florange il y
avait un repreneur prêt à reprendre
quand mittal lui voulait fermer parce
qu'il était en batik et voulait
privilégier son activité minière
donc ces investissements il désinvesti
c'est dans l'aval pour remonter vers
l'amont c'était sa stratégie mais dans
la mesure où nous ne sommes pas nous
mettre de cette stratégie
mais pourtant l'acier français nous
outil de travail nous les avons
nationalisé plusieurs fois monsieur bara
mais nationaliser la famille de vindelle
s'en souvient c'est distrayant de voir
que finalement c'est un cycle politique
qui suit les crises économiques
donc ce n'est pas un problème
idéologique il faut se départir de cette
idée là c'est un problème pratique et
pragmatique et d'intérêts et de
souveraineté nationale
donc cet acier on a payé pour le garder
et il ya eu des générations de deux
sidérurgistes qui ont peiné dans ses
hauts fourneaux
nous avions le devoir de conserver ses
hauts fourneaux donc j'avais obtenu le
soutien de monsieur borloo de monsieur
breton de monsieur guaino de monsieur
baroin et de monsieur bayrou à droite et
au centre
c'est pas mal bon à gauche et j'avais
obtenu sans d'ailleurs les solliciter
que à la fois monsieur mélenchon madame
le pen disent du bien de cette
nationalisation ce qu'ils avaient fait
donc nous avions 100 % la classe
politique tu es d'accord pour la
nationalisation
c'était rare quand même il fallait en
profiter j'ai pas eu de chance j'ai eu
le président enquêtait contre le premier
ministre
quand finalement décidé d est parti à la
faire et nous avons perdu aux fourneaux
et les emplois ont été supprimés comme
d'habitude j'ai envie de dire mais il y
avait quand même un repreneur qui
voulait faire marcher la boîte etc
avaient des marchés et qui considérait
que c'était rentable donc il n'y a pas
d'autre solution
dans ces cas là que la puissance
publique intervient n 10 bat écoutez moi
je le reprends vous êtes d'accord vous
n'êtes pas d'accord tant pis et on
n'échappera pas à cette reprise en main
de l'économie face à des multinationales
qui se fiche des états et des gens ce
qu'il ya des gens vers les zetas et vos
électeurs ce sont les citoyens français
et quand il ya une solution économique
s'agit pas de nationaliser tout ce qui
est en faillite
or là il n'y avait pas de faillite
c'était des ajustements de cycle un peu
comme dans le sucre voilà j'ai pas
d'autre proposition à vous faire que
celle là mais moi je ça me plairait de
vivre dans un dans un pays où il est
possible
intelligemment et de le faire sous le
contrôle du parlement avec
l'intelligence de la situation dans la
discussion consensuel transpartisane oui
parce que pour moi
l'outil de travail les trans partisan ce
n'est pas un sujet qui appartient à un
parti à un an et nous devrions avoir une
sorte de continuité dans la protection
de nos intérêts et malheureusement ce
n'est pas le cas je le regrette
donc je suis très heureux de pouvoir
exprimer ses idées et ses propositions
devant une assemblée de sénateurs
composites
merci monsieur le ministre ces propos
qui vont droit au but sans langue de
bois c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire et
vous avez compris que c'est aussi
l'esprit qui nous anime
au delà de nos appartenances politiques
d'avoir une vision stratégique sur
l'état de notre pays industriel de notre
pays je vais laisser la parole à notre
notre collègue martial bourquin auteurs
de ce rapport sur la
désindustrialisation et que que vous
connaissez naturellement bien si la
présidente monsieur le ministre très
heureux de nous entendre et d'entendre
une autre conception de delà de la
politique concernant les questions
industrielles
c'est dramatique ce qui est en train de
se passer en france et en europe
enfin en europe faisant attention ce que
les allemands les italiens s'en sortent
un peu mieux que nous et n'hésite pas
comme vous disiez à faire en sorte que
l'état prenne des parts pour éviter
souvent des départs d'entreprise j'étais
hier soir avec les salariés d'alstom
on les a reçus ici au sénat l'ensemble
des gros il pose plusieurs questions
est-ce que l'accord signé en 2014 entre
10 et l'état français incluait des
dispositions concernant l'activité
turbines à gaz à belfort et si il y a
des
exposition les calades la deuxième
question que je lui dise tu es ce que
l'état pourrait faire annuler le pse à
belfort on regarde sa non conformité
avec l'accord signé en novembre 2014
question extrêmement précise vous avez
répondu un peu à la troisième question
de cette intersyndicale qui avec la
vente dolosive que dont vous avez parlé
est ce que le non respect de l'accord
pourrait remettre en question la vente
de la branche énergie alstom vous ne
savez ni que ce serait une bataille
juridique et je pense que vous avez
foncièrement raison je m'imagine un seul
instant à seul instant qu'un français
aillent aux états unis faire ce que dit
à fait ben écoutez pour le minimum sont
des milliards de da monde et peut-être
même la prison parce que j'ai vu que ça
se faisait
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas lu le livre
de cet homme faut le lire faut le lire
alors voilà il ya une réforme
constitutionnelle qui est en cours tout
ça le parlement voit les trains passer
est-ce qu'il faut paraît armé le
parlement parce que nous faisons des
rapports nous ne sommes pas entendus
lorsque des décisions aussi importantes
se prennent
est ce que les commissions économiques
des deux assemblées ne devrait pas être
réunies pour qu'elle prenne position sur
ces questions
voilà dernière chose excusez moi je ne
pourront pas être trop long est ce que
le ministre de l'époque et maintenant le
président n'a pas sa responsabilité
personnelle engagé sur ce dossier
d'alstom et de general electric
il me semble qu'il a laissé passer les
trains et il me semble qu'il faut lui
demander des comptes et 6 lits à demain
un procès qui sauvent j'ai vu que le
député marc l'ex avait porté plainte
est-ce que ça nos actions avec un accord
qui avaient des clauses qui nous
permettait est-ce que
la responsabilité personne d'emmanuel
bacon n'est pas engagée sur ce dossier
je vais prendre l'ensemble des questions
si tu es demandé à mes cheveux bourquin
sa deuxième question j'ai pas eu le
temps de prendre un autre précisément
alors est ce que l'état pourrait faire
annuler le pse à belfort on regarde sa
non conformité à l'accord signé en
accord avec en novembre 2014 à dire en
quelque sorte
aujourd'hui la direccte la direccte de
du territoire de belfort dit nous on
attend les ordres du gouvernement
et à chaque fois qu'il demande le maire
ait l'air de belfort ne donne pas une
salle hadji parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
de plan social
il ya une union sacrée de l'ensemble des
parties de toute la région pour refuser
de donner une salle et qui niait
négociations sur le plan social on veut
négociations sur un projet industriel
merci martial je vais laisser la parole
à m me line renaud garabédian ensuite à
michel raison
merci même présidente monsieur le
ministre j'aurai deux questions à vous
poser l'une qui concerne l'extra
territorialité et l'autre qui concerne
la politique industrielle
je souhaiterais revenir sur
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
et qui a pu fragiliser comme voulait
vivre à l'heure certaines de nos
entreprises notamment alstom et qui a
participé à leur cession il apparaît que
les procédures judiciaires qui sont
engagées à l'encontre des groupes
étrangers servent les intérêts de
grandes entreprises américaines et en
clients tirent des avantages économiques
substantielles à l'échelle européenne
peut-on imaginer un outil qui
permettrait de lutter contre cet état de
fait par exemple dans le cadre de la
négociation de taffetas ma deuxième
question dont porte sur la politique
industrielle la liste des secteurs qui
sont concernés par le contrôle des
investissements étrangers dont vous avez
était à l'origine a été large il ya
quelques mois par bruno le maire la loi
pacte récemment adoptée renforce
également la protection des intérêts
publics lors des investissements dans
les entreprises sensibles
que pensez vous de ces nouvelles
dispositions et surtout considérez-vous
que désormais tout a été fait ou au
moins prévu dans les textes
au niveau juridique pour protéger notre
industrie est en amont l'état dispose
t-il aujourd'hui d'un système de veille
qui veille stratégique pour nos
entreprises et nos filières qui sont
aujourd'hui les plus exposés merci dont
ensuite viviane artigalas merci et
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
merci pour votre intervention je suis
rassuré que votre nouveau métier ne vous
a pas rendu mielleux ce que vous n'avez
jamais été une question assez précise et
un but à discrète concernant monsieur
hugues bélé bélé a eu beau parcours de
fonctionnaires mis en disponibilité en
2011 il a représenté l'état au sein de
six vies paul qui exportent le savoir
faire français en matière de maintien de
l'ordre en 2013 il fait son entrée en
politique dans votre cabinet comme
conseiller en 2014
jusqu'en 2016 il est conseillé
financement export de monsieur macro
ministre de l'économie et en 2017 ce
haut fonctionnaire prolonge sa mise en
disponibilité en devenant directeur des
affaires institutionnelles c'est general
electric c'est à dire le lobbyiste
general electric et le voilà enfin
propulsé en avril dernier à la tête de
general electric france pour défendre
les intérêts de la multi nationales donc
première question ce monsieur at il
participé à l'accord négocié entre vous
le président ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure et la seconde question compte
tenu de son palmarès évoqué précédemment
se trouve-t-il selon vous en situation
de prise illégale d'intérêt deuxième
question concernant le il ya eu un
rapport préconisant la vente de la
branche énergie quand a eu lieu ce
rapport quand avez vous été au courant
de ce rapport
quelles étaient ses préconisations et
qu'ils avaient demandé ce rapport
merci là des questions qui ne sont pas
non plus mielleuse viviane artigalas et
ensuite c'est un serge babary oui merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
moi j'ai deux questions aussi les
difficultés d'alcatel l'avait amené à
fusionner avec l'américain lucent en
2006 et qui a été absorbée aussi par
nokia en 2015
l'état avait obtenu à l'époque la
garantie d'un droit de regard en cas de
cession par nokia de l'actif très
stratégique que constitue du alcaltel
submarine networks spécialisée dans les
câbles sous marin de fibre optique alors
que les chinois sont en train de
consolider la filière leur filière de
leur filière de câbles sous marins et
que alcatel sous marine prend du retard
l'état voudrait racheter un acteur
français rachète cette filiale mais se
heurte au refus de nokia or et ont pu
éviter cela en mettant des garanties
plus importantes à l'époque le numérique
devienne un enjeu stratégique
extrêmement important
et que patrick thil faire maintenant
pour rétablir les choses en sachant
aussi que dans le cadre de l'emploi
nokia n'a pas respecté ses engagements
particulièrement sur la recherche et
l'innovation donc se trouve aussi en
retard sur ces questions là ma deuxième
question porte sur les concessions
hydroélectriques qui sont des outils
stratégiques de gestion de l'eau et de
l'énergie en france vont sans doute sur
injonction de l'europe être mise en
concurrence
or il je pense qu'il serait important
que là aussi des investisseurs étrangers
ne prennent pas le contrôle de cette
gestion de l'eau la législation
française actuelle nous permette elle
nous permettrait tel d'éviter cela merci
viviane serge babary ensuite daniel
grenier
merci madame heures du jour je me je
reviens sur un sujet évoqué par notre
présidente dans son propos liminaire
concernant la réforme du dispositif
d'intelligence économique et de la
connaissance des outils de l'état pour
mieux anticiper les conséquences
économiques des cessions d'entreprises
françaises le dispositif d'intelligence
économique de l'état fait l'objet de
très nombreuses modifications depuis sa
création en 2003 la dernière en date est
actée dans un décret du 20 mars dernier
très récemment donc relatif à la
gouvernance de la politique de sécurité
économique
le directeur général des entreprises est
également commissaire à l'information
stratégique et la sécurité économique
cissé et dirige un service dédié à cette
fonction il a notamment pour mission de
contribuer à la détection et
d'identification des opérations
d'investissements étrangers caracter
interministériel de ces travaux est
garanti par un comité de liaison qui a
réuni l'ensemble des ministères et les
services de renseignement sous l'égide
du hd du sgdsn secrétariat général
défend sa sécurité nationale
rattaché au premier ministre
estimez vous cette nouvelle architecture
et pertinente les moyens mis en oeuvre
par l'état sur ce sujet sont ils
suffisants à l'heure où la guerre
économique bat son plein mais j'ai bien
compris que rien ne remplace et à la
volonté politique
merci serge daniel grémillet oui merci
madame effrayante
monsieur ministre merci beaucoup pour
votre intervention
j'aurai deux questions la première à une
question plus tôt mais surtout de dire
combien je partage la dégradation de la
perte de contrôle qui nous amène à la
perte de la recherche d'innovations qui
nous amène à la perte de production
on est dans l'europe est effectivement
au sein de l'union européenne on peut
pas dire que la france brille par sa
performance industrielle on est plutôt à
la traîne
on est en permanence en train de
s'appauvrir et surtout ce constat fait
qu'on est en train de perdre des
cerveaux et de la jeunesse sur l'intérêt
industriel dans notre pays j'aurai ma
question c'est est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur la manière d'
armer la france est peut-être plus
l'union européenne si on veut peser face
aux états unis et à la chine
après ces élections européennes mais
surtout juste avant un break site
difficile et qui va obligatoirement
obligé l'europe à réagir nombre de
présents par an j'aurai deux questions
supplémentaires
vous savez monsieur le ministre qu on a
un dispositif en france extrêmement
louer qui s'appelle le crédit impôt
recherche très utilisée qui est un
formidable outil pour que la recherche
et le développement se passe en france
vous avez dit tout est alors qu'un
certain nombre d'entreprises délocaliser
y compris leurs centres de recherche
voilà quelle quelle est votre position
entre cet atout qui nous semble être
enfin ce dispositif qui ne s'en remettra
un atout et puis finalement ce que vous
nous disiez tout à l'heure de la
délocalisation y compris de la recherche
et de l'innovation
et puis deuxième petite question qui va
qui est un petit peu à côté de notre
sujet mais je profite de votre présence
pour vous la posez vous savez qu'au
sénat nous nous sommes opposés à la
privatisation
aéroports de paris pratiquement de façon
unanime sur sur les bancs certes avec
des raisons très différentes évidemment
entre la france entre le groupe
communiste et le groupe l'est
républicain
certains pensant qu'il s'agissait d'un
actif stratégique certains autres dont
j'étais pensant que nous opposons pas
sur le principe de la privatisation mais
sur la médiocrité du cahier des charges
voilà j'aurais aimé avoir votre avis sur
également sur ce sujet puisque nous vous
avons voilà je me permets de vous poser
cette question
voilà je voulais c'est répondre alors je
vais tâcher de répondre le plus
précisément possible si je suis pas prêt
si vous me rappeler chacun chacune à
l'ordre alors qu'est ce que nous avions
prévu dans l'accord je réponds à
monsieur burqa qu'est ce que nous avions
prévu dans l'accord sur
le gaz qui objet fait l'objet de nous
avions prévu que pendant trois ans et ne
pourrait pas touché pendant trois ans
donc c'était 2015 de 3 en 2018 pourrait
pas toucher à l'état des implantations
et des emplois dans en france donc
c'était général donc ça touchait le gaz
voilà parce que cela n'affectait pas en
effet à ce tome mais ça ça a duré trois
ans c'est tout ce que nous avions fait
donc mais c'est ce que ce qui a permis
puisque à l'époque je me souviens les
syndicats s'alarmaient déjà
puisque c'était une acquisition
intérieur de general electric sur le gaz
et turbines à gaz s'alarmer déjà et donc
l'accord a permis de bloquer les choses
comme ça ça a été respectée mais nous ne
sommes plus en 2018
nous sommes en 2019 l'accord de ce point
de vue là haut peut-être qu'on aurait dû
mettre pendant cinq ans mais il aura
attendu deux ans de plus donc le sujet
c'est pas finalement est ce qu'il faut
faire des accords pour gelé parce que
les entreprises ont toujours besoin de
se restructurer on ne peut pas non plus
les bloquer indéfiniment donc moi je
serais partisan que on cherche à
contrôler nos outils de production et
donc de reprendre le contrôle dans un
certain nombre de secteurs et d'ailleurs
si j'avais une proposition à faire
puisqu'il faut vaut mieux faire des
propositions que de remuer le passé
ce serait qu'aujourd'hui nous pouvons
parfaitement racheté dans la déconfiture
générale de ji des morceaux de ce qui a
été pris dans la sphère de la vente
la branche énergie alstom general
electric par exemple pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous ne pourrions pas
racheter la branche nucléaire
c'est une question de souveraineté c'est
une unité de production rentable elle
pèse à peu près un milliard de chiffre
d'affaires
elle a une rentabilité d'environ d'après
de mémoire des anciens d'alstom qui sont
passés gerald étriqué qui nous parlent
et qu'ils souhaitent eux elle pèse à peu
près en résulta 10% très bon pour
l'industrie lot de toute façon elle est
invendable à d'autres que la france ce
qu'il y a il ya le fameux veto que
j'avais négocié qui restent pendants sur
toutes les décisions de cette unité
et surtout elle concerne les îlots
conventionnels des centrales nucléaires
toute la maintenance et le service sur
un parc nucléaire très important aux
états unis en russie et y compris sur
les centrales rose atom + nôtres de 58
edf
nous avons aujourd'hui une disponibilité
de general electric sur ce sujet et je
crois que des investisseurs privés
pourraient parfaitement s'unir à une
impulsion d'edf et de la bpi en
minoritaire qui nous permettrait de
reprendre le contrôle
donc voilà ma présidente si vous avez
quelques influences auprès du
gouvernement pressé s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît le premier ministre qui vous
est en rapport de responsabilité
politique
le ministre de l'économie de réunir le
tour de table
j'y prêterais bénévolement mes efforts
le tour de table pour aller capitalisé
une société à capitaux publics et privés
à majorité privé comme ça on dira pas
que c'est l'état l'état l'état et a
heureusement qu'il est là et nous
pourrions reprendre le nucléaire
français sur nos bâtiments militaires
sur le parc nucléaire et je suis sûr
qu'on trouverait beaucoup
d'investisseurs qui sont intéressés à la
technologie française pour qu'elle
revienne dans le giron français
une proposition que je fais j'ai déjà
fait devant les syndicats belfortain je
leur fais je refais devant le devant le
sénat est ce que l'état
deuxième question de monsieur bourquin
est ce que l'état peut aujourd'hui faire
juger le ps est non conforme réponse oui
l'état est parti réponse oui il le peut
et en tout cas il a les moyens négocier
quelque chose avec general electric
ils sont les turbines à gaz sont en bas
de cycle
mais ça va remonter donc il faut
maintenir l'outil industriel
donc dans ce cadre là la négociation
elle doit être
qu'est-ce que nous préservons comme
outil industriel
s'agissant de désinstallation
belfortaine enfin sur la question de la
responsabilité du parlement
le parlement arrive quand quand les
décisions étaient prises c'est un
contrôle a posteriori nécessaire vous
pouvez vous devriez imaginer des
commission denquête sur le sujet j'avais
dire quasi permanente émission les
missions permanentes dans quai de
contrôle vous avez le pouvoir de le
faire moi j'ai fait une mission quand
j'étais jeune parlementaire 20 ans sur
les paradis fiscaux
ça a été la mission la plus longue d'un
cinquième république a duré deux ans et
demi pendant deux ans il n'y a pas de
limites c'est pas une commission de 2
ans et demi on est allé enquiquiner tous
les paradis fiscaux européens et on
faisait un rapport sur chaque paradis
fiscal et à chaque fois on sorte un
rapport bazar et on a obtenu des retours
des reculades de la part il compris au
luxembourg monaco à jersey guernesey
on a ouvert le débat dans tous les pays
européens comme ça on avait fait ça avec
monsieur peillon qui était président de
la commission moi j'étais le méchant
rapporteur je peux vous dire que ça nous
étions pionniers sur les paradis fiscaux
parce que depuis tout toute la
législation sur les échanges
automatiques le président obama
c'en est saisi il est vrai que le
terrorisme s'en est mêlé bref on a eu
des résultats donc vous devriez faire
une mission permanente assemblée
nationale sénat sur toutes les questions
industrielles et dès qu'un problème par
fouzia les setters ut1 le le paradis
avait changé de camp monsieur le
sénateur mal alors après il ya eu une
responsabilité de monsieur macron bah
écoutez vous vous êtes nombreux à me
questionner sur les responsabilités des
uns et les autres je sais que j'ai une
responsabilité politique de des
décisions comprendre moi j'ai une
responsabilité politique genre en compte
ici
si dans le cas des différentes
procédures ouvertes on vient me demander
mon avis mon témoignage je le donnerais
volontiers je réponds de mes actes cela
fait partie de l'honneur de la fonction
d'une fonction politique responsabilités
politiques les syndicats m'interroge
m'invite à venir parler je le fais le
sénat me convoque je défère et voilà et
donc la responsabilité politique de la
part d'un ancien ministe cetc de ce2
d'accepter de rendre des comptes
la reddition des comptes a été inventé
au vème siècle avant jésus christ ou le
siècle de périclès dans la démocratie
athénienne et vous savez à l'époque la
reddition des comptes lorsque dans
l'agora un magistrat avait mal agi
cela pouvait se terminer par la
lapidation
nous n'en sommes heureusement pas là
nous avons des commissions dans la quête
amical ou courtoise on réponde nos actes
donc nous avons bien civilisé la
reddition des comptes
je trouve parfois que on devrait un peu
la durcir voilà je crois pas aller au
delà alors après madame reno a posé un
certain nombre de deux questions sur ce
que nous pourrions faire dans le cadre
d'une riposte bien entendu sur les lois
extraterritoriales américaine d'abord
dans le cadre des négociations au plus
haut niveau l'union européenne ne sait
jamais
emparé de ce sujet sur l'anti-dumping je
vous savez que les procédures de défense
anti dumping relève du dialogue
commission conseille et qu' il n'y a pas
de majorité au conseil pour faire
prévaloir même les propositions les plus
les plus audacieuses de la commission
quand il faut passer de 16 % de droits
de douane antidumping sur de l'acier
spécial chinois à 30 % c'est-à-dire rien
38 décide tout seul de mettre 250 %
quand il ya une quantité une attitude
dumping et après on plaide devant
l'organe de différends de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
nous on n'arrive pas à avoir une
majorité pour faire ça pourquoi parce
que chaque pays européen des intérêts
différents et divergents vis-à-vis de la
chine et des états unis
les allemands ne veulent pas d'anti
dumping
parce que eux leur seul horizon c'est
combien vont-ils ventes de voitures aux
etats-unis et en chine
et là ils savent très bien qu un à un
des deux il va falloir choisir
donc nous n'avons pas de process de
décisionnaires européen c'est une grande
paralytique l'union européenne sur la
question économique
donc non pas de protection donc il faut
revenir aux états et puis tant pis nous
prendrons nos mesures et nous tenterons
est la france en a vu d'autres elle
pourra prendre les moyens de se défendre
et de reconstituer son potentiel
économique
ça ça prendra dix ans c'est l'oeuvre
d'une génération à venir qui à
l'évidence pas celle là qui vont comme
cette prise de conscience des trans
partisane elle concerne tous les tous
les parlementaires les citoyens et bien
je crois que c'est c'est cet espoir
qu'il faut qu'il faut nourrir est ce que
les lois sont suffisantes pour moi oui
vous avez tout l'arsenal
il manque juste des gens pour les
appliquer d'où l'action du parlement qui
doit être à mon avis plus agressif plus
offensif sur son contrôle
je ne peux que vous y encourage et
monsieur raison me pose des questions
sur mon ancien collaborateur monsieur
hugues baylet
alors ma position j'ai déjà exprimées à
beaucoup de journalistes
d'abord monsieur hubert est en train mon
cabinet comme chargé de mission dans la
cellule de restructuration qui était
piloté par un mes conseillers dont il
n'a jamais eu à connaître des dossiers
stratégiques jeu le jeu peut l'attester
tout à fait en toute sincérité
en tout cas sous mon ministère pour moi
c'est un homme parfaitement honnête je
ne par ailleurs je crois savoir que
ensuite il était embauché par mon
successeur qui était monsieur macron je
crois qu'il s'est soumis à la commission
de déontologie qui a rendu un avis sur
le sujet aucun fonctionnaire de bercy ou
membres de cabinets qui se propulse dans
un secteur ne peut s'en sortir sans
avoir saisi la commission de déontologie
donc la commission de déontologie on en
pense qu'on en veut et peut être un peu
plus souple que la commission de
contrôle de la vie politique les la
haute autorité qui concerne les
parlementaires les ministres
d'ailleurs il conviendrait de les
fusionner pour qui et unicité du risque
prudence
enfin elle ne laisse pas non plus faire
toujours n'importe quoi donc moi je peux
attester de cela après monsieur baylet
il mène sa carrière que comme il
l'entend mais je ne je ne je dirais
plutôt que il a respecté les procédures
à mon sens alors ça ne fait pas de lui
le 5e
faudrait voir en lui ou à l inverse on
ne peut pas considérer que la politique
qu'il mène au nom de general electric et
est enviable
je peux pas distinguons les personnes
des des décisions
je pense que c'est pas si mal alors il
ya eu un rapport sur la vente dastum
puisque pendant c'était votre question
monsieur raison puisque pendant l'année
2013 je n'ai cessé d'avoir des relations
de travail avec monsieur kron le patron
d'alstom qui passe sa vie passé sa vie
dans mon bureau à venir me demander de
faire pression sur la sncf pour vendre
des tgv ce que je faisais bien
volontiers qui passait son temps à me
demander d'intervenir auprès de tel ou
tel chef d'état pour vendre ses
centrales que je faisais bien volontiers
cela faisait partie de ma mission de mon
travail de défendre la france à
l'étranger de défendre les entreprises
en rapport avec la commande publique
ce que je considère que la commande
publique est mal orienté dans notre pays
donc tout ça je trouvais ça tout à fait
normal mais je pose est toujours la même
question à monsieur monsieur croc
sachant que monsieur oui et
l'actionnariat qui avait remplacé l'état
en 2003 à la demande de la commission
européenne voulait sortir ce qu'il avait
d'autres problèmes liés à la la
aux télécommunications il avait investi
de façon importante et où ils étaient
attaqués par de nouveaux intervenants
qui avait autorisé le gouvernement
précédent de monsieur sarkozy
free bon c'était ça son obsession donc
j'avais compris que monsieur bruit que
vous voulez sortir donc par qu'il allait
ton le remplacer quelle était la
stratégie d'actionnariat futur d'alstom
à chaque fois je cros et lui des je sais
combien de fois un jeu les revues même
le soutien à l'ambassade d'abou dhabi où
on était allé faire un voyage pour
défendre alstom s'était vu dans un
aparté dans l'appartement d'ambassadeur
la résidence de notre ambassadeur
monsieur azouaou et je me souviens qu'il
y ait en tête à tête mais il n'y a aucun
problème
on va s'en occuper et je vous tiendrai
au courant mais comme j'avais le temps
passait et que moi je n'avais pas de
vision stratégique autre que celle dans
laquelle je me remettais dans l'esprit
monsieur kron et bien ggg commandé à
roland becker une analyse mondiale du
secteur de l'énergie et de la mobilité
ferroviaire pour qu'on ait une une
vision nous au tonneau et croisées avec
la direction générale des entreprises
qui étaient sous mon autorité qu a rendu
un rapport en février 2014 car rapport
qui était assez nette qui disait tout
consolide une consolidation était
nécessaire à terme pas tout de suite et
pas d'urgence que nous pouvions nous
même imaginer beaucoup de scénarios
alors le scénario général écrit qui
était envisagé c'était des dégâts
considérables
donc on le savait février 2014
l' affaire a éclaté en mai 2014 et la
décision était prise en juin 2014 et
puis il y a eu
[Musique]
il y a eu l'analyse aussi siemens qui
était meilleure mais qui posait d'autres
problèmes ce sujet est revenu plus tard
il y avait la nuit vise mitsubishi qui
elle était très bonne d'ailleurs pour ça
que j'ai pris contact avec mitsubishi
dans la tempête
donc tout ça était sur la table l'état
n'était pas démuni je l'avais armé
intellectuellement pour faire face à la
situation et faire face à la trahison de
monsieur kron voilà considère que le
sucre on a trahi son pays il ya quand
même des limites à vendre en pièces
détachées une entreprise qui est un des
biens presque commun de notre pays pour
se protéger personnellement et s'éviter
la prison à raison d d
des actes condamnables reconnu par la
justice américaine contre alstom
voilà l'histoire c'est une histoire très
grave de trahison des élites
alors ensuite donc j'ai répondu monsieur
raison à votre votre question madame
artigalas me pose la question sur la
sphère nokia alcatel a encore l'histoire
malheureusement c'est une de celles
peut-être dans laquelle nous aurions pu
faire autrement
je me souviens du président d'alcatel
qui est venu me voir pour me demander
d'interdire huawei j c'est une très
bonne idée et en contrepartie on ne fait
pas de plan social continue à investir
vous restez vous ne vendez pas dit
d'accord j'ai jamais pu obtenir
l'interdiction de huawei c'est
finalement le président entre hommes
qu'il a fait mais c'était un des
éléments qui avaient mis monsieur cave
emile président de d'alcatel sur la
table pour maintenir alcatel en france
j'étais d'accord j'ai perdu l'arbitrage
la défense était d'accord mais on
n'avait pas les chefs qu'il fallait
voilà vous avez un point intéressant
parce que ça débat a eu lieu dès 2013 14
alors la conséquence après alcatel se
faire acheter par nokia nous notre
position était de dire si on attend les
courbes peut-être quelques et elle
rachètera nokia au lieu d'être racheté
par nokia
il suffisait d'attendre bon et puis
après je suis parti les choses ont été
ont été faites mais c'est un point
dans lequel évidemment après c'est
difficile de rattraper les morceaux vous
parlez des câbles sous-marins nous
sommes bien averti à l'époque c'était un
sujet stratégique
alors monsieur le sénateur bart him as
oui vous avez posé la question des
concessions des concessions de barrages
de barrage barrages bah écoutez c'est
une politique de l'union européenne de
mettre sur le marché les outils de
production électrique
personnellement je pense que ça n'a
aucun intérêt pour la france
ces barrages ont été amortis sont des
investissements qui ont été faits il ya
un siècle ont été entretenues pour la
plupart entretenu on va donner des
barrages donnée des barrages pour créer
les conditions de la concurrence la
concurrence dans une dans une situation
de monopole n'a aucun sens donc moi je
vois pas ce qui empêche gouvernement
dire non voilà une union européenne n'a
pas à je crois et la commission encore
mois n'a aucune légitimité pour décider
de ce qu'on va faire de nos barrages moi
c'est ma position est d'ailleurs un
président de la république qui dirait à
l'union européenne écoute et
occupez-vous d'autres choses et laissez
nous tranquilles je peux vous dire que
ça se passerait comme ça donc ça c'est
là c'est comme ça que ça marche avec
union européenne donc s'ils veulent
privatiser nos barrages qu'ils le
fassent en nous mais nos barrages c'est
nos barrages c'est un bien public c'est
un bien commun ne vont pas à privatiser
concession bas alors monsieur le
sénateur babarit me pose la question de
l'état de l'architecturé moi j'ai pas de
danalyse sur les réformes qui ont
je sais mais très difficile d'ailleurs
de me plonger parce que c'est assez
complexe
je vois que vous avez bien situer la
question moi je crois que ce qui compte
ce sont ces la volonté de faire après
vous pouvez faire des tas de comités
théodule des réunions
interministérielles puis y'a demande -
as passe ça c'est la loi du genre
c'est la loi de l'entropie c'est la loi
de l'entropie qu'on arrive à
caractériser dans les bureaucraties plus
y'a demande responsable moyen de
responsables donc moins il ya de
réalisation donc là est beaucoup de
monde donc je dois vous dire je suis pas
du tout convaincu mais laissons une
chance à ce dispositif de réveiller nos
intérêts monsieur gainey est sénateur a
posé la question du réarmement de
l'union européenne j'ai un peu répondu
en vous disant que l'union européenne ne
sait pas prendre de décision est
profondément divisée dans la guerre
économique mondiale
donc vous n'aurez pas d'autre solution
pour nous défendre
non pas d'attendre comme godot que
l'union européenne veulent bien nous
défendre mais ne rompt pas d'autre
solution que d'avoir des stratégies
nationales
en attendant deux exemples taxe gaffe
pareil il va falloir prendre notre
courage à demain affronter le monde
seuls pas passer notre vie à dire que
l'union européenne nous protège ne nous
protège pas elle nous met à nu face à
l'adversité c'est le cas dans
l'agriculture c'est le cas de
l'industrie
les chevaux de troie sont multiples
grâce à l'union européenne
au lieu de nous protéger elle nous
empêche de nous organiser
donc moi je n'ai pas du tout la croyance
que l'union européenne pourraient nous
protéger ça s'éteint c'est une fable qui
était racontée pour entretenir une
fausse religion mais pour moi la réalité
c'est que nous n'avons plus besoin nous
avons une urgence nationale qui est la
défense de nos intérêts quel intérêt
supérieur à tous les autres parce que le
pain des français c'est l'économie
les fans mois des français c'est
l'économie et donc et la puissance de la
france c'est l'économie donc si on ne
s'en occupe pas qu'on attend que l'union
européenne veut bien ceci veuille bien
cela mais écoutez vous rendez vous dans
dix ans et on sera à 5%
là où nous sommes encore à 10 voilà donc
je n'y crois pas alors non si on veut
bien m'en convaincre peut-être mais je
n'ai pas l'expérience de quelque chose
qui pourrait m'en convaincre
j'en suis désolé et comme je parle sans
à titre purement personnel est tout à
fait librement
je vous donne mon sentiment parce que
vous avez eu la gentillesse et mais fait
honneur de me le demander
alors sur le seuil r je suis afin un
partisan déclaré du cr qui est une arme
anti délocalisation mais en moins nous
avons quelques cas donc il faut défendre
le crédit impôt recherche c'est ce qui
nous reste quand même en termes
scientifiques
si le secteur numérique est si puissant
c'est parce qu'on a ça il faudrait
peut-être modéré l'administration
fiscale qui passe sa vie
dès qu'il ya un seuil est à organiser
immédiatement le contrôle surtout sur
les pme qui ne peuvent pas se défendre
ça si vous pouvez regarder ce point
parce que les pme n'ont pas des moyens
considérables en battant batterie
arsenault de juristes jeu dès que vous
avez le sait hier il vous est octroyé
puis après nous à un contrôle fiscal
c'est automatique est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas faire un contrôle fiscal avant
d'octroyer on gagnerait du temps ça
éviterait des moments difficiles pour
les entreprises
voilà alors après me poser la question
de la privatisation d'aéroports de paris
moi je suis opposé à toute forme de
privatisation de monopole un monopole
public est sous le contrôle du parlement
un monopole privé né sous le contrôle de
personnes et donc comme c'est un
monopole
quel est le contre-pouvoir qui
s'applique aucun si les privés si les
publics
si vous aviez en
nous a si l'état avait encore les
autoroutes nous pourrions intervenir sur
le montant des péages qui est un sujet
de société fondamental où nous pourrions
dire on augmente les péages sur les
usagers de l'autoroute pour financer tel
ou tel ou tel chose qui était d'ailleurs
le cas donc aéroports de paris écoutez
c'est assez simple il ya eu 36 aéroports
qui ont été privatisées dans le monde
une minorité les résultats sont assez
connus on voit que toutes les taxes
d'atterrissage les droits les redevances
infligé aux compagnies aériennes ont
bondi et ont donc provoqué des
optimisations de profits pour les
investisseurs dans les aéroports ce qui
est normal mais leur donner le pouvoir
de le faire pourquoi se priverait-il et
donc la régulation n'existe pas voilà
voilà donc moi je suis tout à fait
opposé cette privatisation et je vais
signer l'appel au référendum parce que
c'est comme citoyen j'ai le droit de le
faire je crois
voilà et j'invite tous les citoyens à se
joindre à cette initiative après on
débattra la décision sera prise par les
français on ne peut pas les préjugés
mais je donnerai mon point de vue
puisque vous m'autorisez à le faire je
le fais y at il d'autres d'autres
questions que vous voudriez posée oui
michel à madame la présidente que c'est
un tout petit complément d'information
sur ce qui aurait pu être bien avec une
reprise par mitsubichi de jeu mitsubishi
c'est un conglomérat japonais comme une
halle conglomérat allemand siemens
conglomérat indien afrique
nous nous avions des conglomérats
c'était la compagnie générale
d'électricité où il y avait thompson
alstom et tout ça
technicolor d'énormes conglomérat que
nous avons démantelé en coupant en
disant il faut se concentrer sur le
coeur de métier
pas du tout les conglomérats ont survécu
dans la crise les entreprises qui se
sont concentrés sur leur coeur de métier
l'on dise pas ou été rachetés donc c'est
une leçon pour l'avenir dont il faut
construire en france des conglomérats
nous devons c'est à dire avoir dix
métiers dans une seule entreprise
c'est plus difficile à gérer mais faut y
penser pour l'avenir et donc nous
devrons imaginer par exemple que saint
gobain puisse racheter lafarge et là
nous avions un conglomérat btp
et là on n'aurait pas eu holcim imaginer
que thales reprennent alstom et la ns
ferroviaire puisqu'ils sont très bons
dans le signal il est là nous aurions un
conglomérat a cédé proposions jamais
alors mitsubishi qui est un conglomérat
avait lé marché différent d'alstom et
puis il y avait il ya une entente
culturelles entre la france et le japon
qu'on a expérimenté dans renault nissan
malgré les derniers évènements
c'est quand même des années des années
de coopération et donc je crois que ça
aurait été une bonne idée
est-ce que c'était possible j'ai
rencontré le président de vichy qu'il
est à fait favorables à commencer la
discussion
j'ai rencontré est venu à mon téléphone
en direct
nous étions en direct peut pas aller
plus loin je ne sais pas ce qu'est ce
qu'elle aurait donné mais il est évident
que le board
le conseil d'administration de alstom
qui avait été verrouillée par monsieur
croc puisqu'il avait fait signer
l'obligation de voter comme le président
à tous ses membres par avance et versez
un surcroît de jetons de présence voilà
ça s'appelle comme vous voulez puis vous
aimez qualifiés et comportements
réfléchissiez monsieur le sénateur et
bien nous pouvons imaginer que
[Musique]
toute autre solution que j'ai râlé trick
été rejeté par le bal conseil du tracé
ovale sommes donc mitsubishi comme le
reste mais je reste convaincu
historiquement que tu t'étais une idée
intéressante et c'était dans le rapport
à l'an dernier
j'ai remis à la commission d' enquête
sur alstom de l'assemblée nationale ce
document je vais essayer de vous
transmettre comme ça vous pourrez
rétrospectivement réfléchir à nos futurs
conglomérat avec qui quoi comment
pardonnez moi mais du coup une autre
question me vient en parlant de
conglomérats où on va dans quelques
temps être être questionné sur
finalement un démantèlement d'edf en
tout cas une modification d'edf qui va
probablement se spécialiser par grande
part grande activité
est-ce que c'est pas contraire à la
position vous venez de l'évoquer j'ai
pas compris à quoi ça sert mais voilà
j'ai pas compris alors je vais pas les
informations je vais me renseigner mais
je n'ai pas compris quel est l'objectif
quand on a je rappelle que l'électricité
comme les chemins de fer en france était
historiquement avant la guerre la
première guerre mondiale deuxième guerre
mondiale
tu es des sociétés privées éparpillés
sur le territoire la constituer un
réseau de manière à optimiser sa gestion
quand vous avez un réseau vrement le
couper en tranches et revenir à la
situation antérieure public privé ceci
cela regardait ce qu'ont fait les
allemands
quand on a un compte l'union européenne
avait obligé qu'on découpe le réseau de
l'exploitation du réseau ferroviaire
finalement les allemands audi n'ont pas
du tout non refus des histoires cdu
c'est du fait du sanskrit de 2,2
deux talibans du droit européen
c'est à peu près ça et donc nous on n'en
veut pas on garde deutsch bahn en une
seule entité
nous on a fait quoi on l'a coupé en deux
conformément ce qu'on est les bons
élèves de l'europe malheureusement et on
a fait 2 2 structures vous avez rff et
sncf et rff à accumuler de la dette et a
commencé à faire infliger sncf le prix
de sa dette puisque c'était déconnecté
on construisait des lignes de façon
déconnectés de leur exploitation c'est
complètement idiot en disant qu'un jour
on va faire la concurrence sur les
lignes
la concurrente accord met fin à la
concurrence pour la baisse des coûts
hors la dette et la hausse des coûts
donc est-ce qu'on pouvait pas mettre
tout ça et bien finalement la refait on
a refait cette unité là bon donc là on
va on va démontrer edf n'inquiétait pas
dans 10 en valeur mais voilà pourquoi
parce que ça n'a pas de sens quand vous
avez un acteur unique est d'ailleurs
monopolistique de quasi monopolistique
de production électricité et c'est
normal qui aujourd'hui peut financer la
construction de centrales pas direct
energie non non pas les moyens puisque
ce sont des services yale ils font du
service à l'usager
donc ça n'a aucun sens et donc c'est en
effet le contraire de ce que nous
devrions faire nous devrions faire des
conglomérats donc edf par exemple
devrait racheter le nucléaire d'alstom
ça c'est une bonne proposition et voilà
pour cette audition d'arnaud montebourg
au sénat sur la suppression de 1000
emplois annoncés par l'américain general
electric dans ses usines françaises
l'ancien ministre du redressement
productif a affirmé que s'il était
aujourd'hui au pouvoir il demanderait
l'annulation de la vente de la branche
énergie d'alstom à l'américain une vente
réalisée en 2014 est selon arnaud
montebourg l'annulation est permise par
les textes de l'accord l'ancien ministre
de l'économie considère également qu'il
faut une stratégie protectionnistes pour
préserver l'industrie française en proie
aux intérêts étrangers et notamment à la
pression américaine
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez revoir tous
nos programmes sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
public sénat
[Musique]